hi my name's Ben most people call me
fuzzy and I work at a company called
tulip and over the past couple of years
we've been adopting a type system on our
untyped JavaScript code base so what I'm
going to be talking about today is
basically the things that I wish I had
known when we started doing this and in
particular there's three big questions
that we keep running into over and over
so one of them is that we'll write some
code and we'll think this this code
looks pretty good and typescript will
run over our code and we'll say yep no
problems there and then we'll get a type
error at runtime and we'll say hey
actually this is pretty obvious like
we're reading way outside the bounds of
the array isn't this why we use
typescript in the first place why didn't
catch that bug for us the the second
question and this one we we probably run
into even more is we're writing some
code and we run typescript over it and
typescript says hey that's a type error
you can't do that but we'll look at the
code again and we'll say hey that that
code actually looks fun I don't think
there's any problem with that code we
run the code we test the code never
throws a type error the code is totally
fine but typescript is still saying that
there's a type error so what's what's up
with that and the last thing is that
sometimes we're digging really deep into
the documentation and we're like man
this is this is pretty confusing it
feels like there's a lot of sort of like
incidental complexity or things that
would be much simpler in Java
or go or some other language we've
worked with why is this type system so
complicated so to answer those questions
we're going to look at a bunch of
different programming languages today
we're gonna look a lot at javascript for
a couple reasons one is that hopefully
most of you have seen some JavaScript
and can follow along with the code the
other thing is that there's two major
type systems for JavaScript there's some
other smaller ones too but the the two
big ones are typescript and flow and so
what's interesting is they have somewhat
different goals
so flows goal is to catch as many types
as possible they want to create a type
system that is not going to let any bugs
any any type errors slip through whereas
as typescript has a little bit you know
it's it's a little bit more flexible
right their goal is to make you more
productive and that means catching bugs
earlier right it's much more productive
catch above during compilation phase
then then once it's out in the wild but
they're willing to make trade-offs and
catch fewer bugs in exchange for other
desirable properties like having the
type system be easy to learn and
producing great error messages so we're
gonna look we're gonna look at a bunch
of JavaScript and compare these two type
systems we're also going to look at some
other languages so we're gonna take a
look at my PI which is a type system for
Python and sorbet which is a very new
type system for Ruby and these these
four type systems over here are called
gradual type systems and all that means
is that they're designed to be added
gradually to an existing code base so
their designs you can have an existing
code base of untyped JavaScript or
untyped or Ruby and you can add this
type system on incrementally which also
means that they're being added on to an
existing language that used to not have
a type system and then to contrast with
those we're gonna look at some
statically typed languages two languages
that had a type system from day one like
go and rust in Java so before we get
started we're gonna be looking at a lot
of code today this is the smallest text
I'm going to use for code so if you're
having trouble reading this there are a
bunch of seats open in the front so come
move on a little closer or if you go to
pip ly / SL - pipes if that's easier you
can follow along on your phone or your
computer okay so before we we dive into
looking at code let's let's talk about a
couple terms that are gonna come up a
whole bunch today so when we think about
a gradual type system there's a couple
goals that we have the first is that
they want to stop you from writing code
that will raise type hours this is why
most people you know adopt a type system
in the first place is to try and catch
errors and so this property is called
soundness so if we built a completely
sound type system then there would never
be any runtime type errors our type
checker would catch every single type
possible type error the flip side of
that goal is that we want our type
system to not stop us from writing code
that isn't going to raise a type error
we want it to only yell at us about type
errors when there is a legitimate type
error and that property is called
completeness so if we build a fully
complete type system then it will never
throw a type a you know will never point
out a type error that isn't a real
legitimate type error and then the third
thing that gradual type systems want to
do and these first two properties we
want that from any type system we use
but those last one is is what's
particularly interesting about gradual
type systems which is that you have this
existing body of code or even if you're
starting from scratch with a brand new
code base you have existing libraries
and idioms and language features that
weren't designed with this type system
in mind and you need to work well with
with those existing language features so
this is where it gets tricky and that's
why it's really interesting to look at
soundness and completeness for gradual
type systems so just to make sure we're
all on the same page about what
soundness and completeness are we're
gonna look at two really simple examples
so typescript has a feature called NE
and you can basically say we're gonna
type this as NE and it's basically a way
of telling typescript hey be unsound
here I don't want you to catch my errors
I just want you to let this through and
so it's gonna let us add a string to an
object and that's gonna throw an error
have weird behavior at runtime and so
this is an example of a program where
typescript is unsound because it's not
going to find a type error at compile
time but there will be a type error at
runtime and then on the flip side here's
an example of wherewhere type script can
be incomplete so here we have a function
that takes either a number or a string
and we do an assertion to make sure that
it's really a number before we use it as
a number and so this is okay this is
never going to throw a type error at
runtime by the time we get to this line
here
we're really sure that a is a number but
if we try to run typescript over this
typescript will will error on this line
and it will say hey it could be either a
number or a string just because it
doesn't understand what what assert
means and what we're using assert to do
so this is an example of a program that
that typescript will point out a type
error but there's no actual way for
there to be a type error at runtime so
this is an example of ways in which
typescript is incomplete okay so to look
at some more interesting examples of
when you might have to trade off
soundness and completeness we're gonna
we're gonna go through three case
studies so the first one is when were
reading values out of an array so here's
a pretty simple program and we have this
function that prints the second element
of an array and the problem is that if
we pass in an array that only has one
element then when we try to read the
second element out of it in JavaScript
if you read outside the bounds of an
array you get the special value
undefined
so the program will continue it executes
there won't be any immediate error but
instead of getting the type that you
expected to get you'll get undefined and
then when we try to pass that into
something that wants specifically a
number we'll get a runtime type error
and so this is another example of
unsoundness if we run typescript or flow
over this program it will say that looks
fine there's no errors here but at
runtime we'll end up getting undefined
we'll pass that into something that
wants a number and we'll get an error so
if we really wanted typescript to
meticulously double-check us we could
say actually this array could have
number or undefined into it and then
every time we read out of that array
types group will say hey this expression
you know second element of array could
be either number undefined you have to
double check it you can't just sort of
pass that into something that expects
specifically a number so why does it
type script just always do this right
typescript could be more sound if every
time you read out of an array it said
well that that thing could be undefined
because you could be out of bounds well
the problem is for loops there's a bunch
of problems but the biggest one is
probably for loops and so the for loop
is a construct where we're constrained
such that the the variable I is never
going to be out of bounds and it's
always safe to use the variable I to
index into array because it's never
going to be less than 0 or more than the
length of the array and so it would be
pretty frustrating if when we try to
write like our really simple for loops
typescript said hey you you can't do
that every time you read out of this
it could be undefined that would be
pretty frustrating and pretty and
complete so it's a trade-off right if
you want to be more sound you can say
every time you index into an array it
could be undefined if you want to be
more complete you can say look we're
gonna trust the programmer to probably
use inbound indices and and we're not
gonna worry about that so we've taken a
pretty deep dive into JavaScript let's
take a look at some other languages so
sorbet is a gradual type checker for
Ruby and Ruby has the same issue as
JavaScript where if you try to access
something outside the bounds of an array
in Ruby you'll get a value called nil
which is sort of equivalent to
JavaScript undefined but sorbet actually
does the sound thing here so sorbet
whenever you try to read out of an array
like this it will return instead of a
string it will return a nillable string
which is basically string or nil and so
why why does our baby
this well it has to do with the
underlying language that in Ruby we
don't generally you know read out of
arrays directly generally we're gonna
use enumerable methods right so we're
gonna use a method like dot each or the
whole other collections of methods that
Ruby has rather than using like a
traditional for loop which doesn't even
really exist in Ruby so basically the
the sorbet team said we wonder if we can
get away with every time you index into
an array giving you back a nillable they
tried it out they took that version of
the sorbet type checker they ran it over
stripes codebase and they found that
actually it worked pretty well it mostly
found real bugs it didn't find a lot of
false positives and so basically they
can get away with with being fully sound
here they don't need to make that
trade-off towards completeness my PI
doesn't have this issue at all again
because of the underlying language so in
Python if you read outside the bounds of
the array that's an immediate error
Python will stop your program right then
it will throw an index error and the
program will continue and so my pipe can
basically say look out of out of bounds
errors that's not my problem that's not
the the problem of the the type system
that's you know a different kind of
problem but I know that if you were able
to read the second index in the second
element of the array and you didn't get
an out-of-bounds error then for sure
this is a float and and I can type check
this as a float and that's going to be
true from most statically typed
languages go and Java and those sorts of
languages tend to throw an immediate
error when you index out of bounds so
okay so there's our first trade-off so
when you read out of an array in some
languages you might get a special value
if your index is out of bounds you might
get undefined new JavaScript or nil and
Ruby and and both typescript and flow
have had to do the less sound thing here
because it would be too incomplete and
too frustrating to make you acknowledge
that every single time you read out of
an array
you could get undefined sorbet on the
other hand because it's in a different
language and a different set of idioms
in a different ecosystem can make a
different trade-off right and they can
say look we're going to be fully sound
here every time you read out of an array
using an index you have to double check
that you didn't get nil and then some
languages get to skip this problem
entirely because as soon as you read
outside of the bounds of an array it
throws an immediate are
so that's it for our first case study
the the next thing we're going to look
at is refinement and validation so
before we can talk about what refinement
and validation is we need to talk about
what refinement is so type refinement is
a feature of most gradual type systems
where they basically will understand the
flow control in your program so here I
have a program and we have some state
that can be either number or no and if I
want to print it out if I just try to
print it as a number I'll get an error
this is sort of why we we like type
systems is that they'll remind us of
things like hey that state could be no
you have to double check whether it's no
before you can pass it into something
that really wants a number and the way
that you can do that in most gradual
type systems is with what's called a
type guard or a runtime type checker and
basically you'll you'll use an if
statement right you'll use the thing
that's already idiomatic in the language
from well before we had type systems to
check that it's not null and then the
type system will basically understand
what you're doing with this if statement
and inside this if block it will let you
treat state as a number right it will
understand that you've refined this type
down from a more general type number or
null and with this type guard you've
refined it down to definitely a number
and so inside this if block you get to
treat it as a number and pass it into
things that want specifically a number
so that's that's type refinement so what
is refinement invalidation well the
problem is sometimes our values are
mutable so let's say we have a function
to refresh our state let's say it's
fetching it from some remote server
could fail might go back to being null
so once we've refined this down from
being Knowle or number two definitely a
number by running this type guard if we
refresh the state it could go back to
being known in this case half of the
time that state's going to go back to
being null and so here's another example
of unsoundness that type script is going
to look at this program and it's gonna
say that's totally fine you did have
number and no but you refined it down to
number so now you get to use it as
number but at run time we could end up
with a type error because that state
could get set back to null so we could
fix that by basically extracting the
value we can take this thing that we're
trying to refine and instead of refining
down this mutable thing that other stuff
could touch we could pull it out into a
constant in the function scope and that
means that nothing else could possibly
change current state and then we were
fine down current state it's fine for us
to
change also its other values we can keep
current state as a double and this is
sound so this is one big difference
between typescript and flow in the
previous example we saw a way in which
typescript and flow are both unsound but
here's where they kind of start
diverging so in flow flow has this
concept of refinement and validation so
when you refine your type down from
Miller number to just number if you call
any external function that could
possibly touch that data flow will drop
your refinement it will invalidate your
refinement and basically on this line
here state is definitely a number and
then flow once you call this external
function it will lose your refinement
and at this point here in the program
the the type is back to being no lor
number and you can't pass it in to print
double so flow basically forces you to
use this pattern of pulling it out into
a local variable we're finding that down
and basically saving it somewhere where
external functions can't change it so
why did typescript choose not to do this
they've thought about it they they
understand this is a problem and they've
sort of explicitly chosen to not
implement this feature and it's
basically because of optimism they
looked at the corpus of JavaScript code
and they said look having these mutable
variables floating around that we change
all the time is kind of considered an
anti-pattern
it's not that common in practice and
like 98% of the time when you call some
external function you're probably
calling like a log function right you're
probably not going to change this
mutable thing that you refine down so
we're gonna be a little optimistic here
we're not going to bother you about it
we're gonna be more complete but less
sound
the other interesting thing and the
other constraint is that it can actually
be pretty tricky to produce good error
messages about refinement and validation
because the line of code where you lost
your refinement where you called into
that external function could be very far
away from the line of code maybe at the
bottom of that F statement where you're
actually trying to use the refinement
and that's another goal of typescript is
to produce really great error messages
whenever it tells you about a type error
so let's let's look at a couple other
languages so for sorbet and my PI does
the same thing they basically say take
the same approaches typescript they say
look most of the time once you've
refined down your type you're not going
to call into some external thing that's
going to go in and mutate that value and
lose your refinement we don't want to
bother you that much we want to be
complete and so they don't implement
refinement and validation
statically typed languages have this
cool superpower that gradually type
languages don't which is that they can
actually bake things into the language
right this was sort of a consideration
from day one when they were building go
for example and so go has has its own
syntax for this where you can have
something in Ingo interface just means
any kind of type we don't know what it
is and you can refine that down until I
can enter a float and basically they
baked it into the syntax of the language
that trick that we did where we pulled
the variable out into the local scope so
other things can't touch it so when you
refine down a value and go you introduce
a new variable in this case N and that's
the thing that gets refined you don't
refine down X because that could change
in the future but you do refine down N
and now you have a new variable that's
that's of the refine type so quick quick
recap of refinement and validation so in
most gradual type systems they
understand runtime checks they
understand that if you use like an if
statement or a switch statement to check
the type of something that inside the if
block they should be able to treat it as
the refine type but they don't
necessarily guarantee that during the
course of running that if block you
never call into something else that
could lose your refinement that could
set your your number back to number or
null so flow is is somewhat unique in
that it handles the sound wave and that
makes it less complete there's a lot of
valid programs that won't type check and
flow because you've called into like a
logging function or something like that
and flow is going to lose your
refinement at that point even though
you're not doing anything wrong okay
we're gonna look at one more case study
we're gonna spend a little bit more time
on this one because this one is is both
a little bit more confusing but also I
think more more interesting and this is
a concept called variance so before we
can talk about what variance is let's
let's talk about a pretty simple program
here so I have a basic type hierarchy I
have shapes and I have two subtypes of
shapes two square on a circle and I have
two functions that on their own look
totally fine I have a function that can
get me the area of a square right and I
have a function that can take an array
of shapes and it can add a shape to it
in this case it's choosing to add a
circle and that's okay because it's an
array of shape so it can hold circles
and squares and triangles in any kind of
shape so it's totally fine to put
Circle onto it but where things where
things get a little weird is when we
start combining them so if we have this
array of squares right we can call out
of shape and pass in our array of
squares and at least in typescript
typescript is going to let us do this
it's gonna look at square and it's gonna
say hey that's a subtype of shape and so
just like we should be able to pass in a
square when something wants a shape we
should also be able to pass in an array
of squares when something wants an array
of shape but at runtime what's gonna
happen is we're going to take this array
of squares we're gonna pass it into out
of shape and out of shape is gonna add a
circle to it and so now we have
something that the type checker thinks
is an array of squares that actually has
circles in it and when we try to use
these values we could end up passing a
circle to something that wants a square
and that's unsound right so here's
here's another example of unsoundness
that type scripts going to look at this
program it's going to say that's totally
fine and then at runtime we'll get a
type error flow does catch this so if
you run this through through flow flow
will throw an error right here and it
will say hey you can't pass an array of
squares into something that wants an
array of shapes we just don't let you do
that if something wants an array of
shapes you need to pass specifically an
array of shapes so what is what is
variance so so this example we've seen
is where we can run into trouble with
variance so variance is about subtyping
and subtyping is just says that that a
type T is a subtype of you if anything
that expects a a you could use a t
instead you can say that T is
substitutable for you and so in this
example a square is substitutable for
shape and and anything that wants a
shape we can give it a square instead so
variance is about how the subtyping
relationship of higher-order things like
an array right generics like an array or
a map from string to two squares or a
function that returns a square or a
function that takes a triangle and any
of these higher-order types that have
other types inside them how they're
subtyping relationships relate to the
the subtyping relationships of the thing
that they're holding so there's four
ways that we can handle variants the
first one is called covariance and this
is what makes intuitive sense to most
people is that a square is a subtype of
shape then an array of squares should be
a subtype of an array of shapes and if a
function wants an array of shapes you
can give it an array of squares we could
also do it the opposite way
it's
called contravariance so if square is a
subtype of shape we can say that an
array of shapes is a subtype of an array
of squares now that seems kind of
confusing and it definitely doesn't make
sense for arrays but we'll see some
cases in just a sec where you would want
contravariance where you would want to
swap the order of the subtyping super
typing relationship we can also say this
is pretty complicated
sometimes we want covariance sometimes
we want contravariance we're not sure
how to do this perfectly so we're gonna
go for the simplest possible thing and
do invariants this is why flow is
storing that error and saying hey you
can't you can't pass an array of squares
to something that wants an array of
shapes is because flow treats arrays
invariantly and so if something wants an
array of shapes you have to pass very
specifically in an array of shapes and
then lastly you can do by variance and
this basically says look sometimes you
want covariance sometimes we want
contravariance we don't want to bother
you too much if we pick the wrong one so
we're gonna let you do either one you
can treat it as either a super type or a
subtype as long as they're they're
related somehow we'll assume that you
have a handle on this and this isn't
just for a race this also holds we can
also think about variance in terms of
functions right functions are another
kind of higher order type that returns
the inner types right a function that
returns a square could be a subtype or a
super type of a function that returns a
shape so okay we've talked about the
different kinds of variance but which
one should we use and the answer is that
it varies by what kind of container it
is the answer is going to be different
for an array for a map for a function
and sometimes there's pretty
straightforward answers so for functions
there's basically just a right answer
which is that they should be covariant
and their return types and contravariant
in their argument types so if I have a
function that takes a rectangle and
returns a rectangle I can construct a
subtype of this function that takes a
shape something that's a super type of
rectangle and returns a square something
that's a subtype of rectangle so this
probably doesn't make sense immediately
so we're gonna break it down and start
building some intuition for when you
might want covariance versus
contravariance so let's look at this
hierarchy so we have entertainment and
that's a super type of music and music
is a super type of death metal
and if we think about producers of these
things right a producer of entertainment
is going to be a super type of a
producer of music and a producer of
music is going to be a super type of a
producer of death metal and the reason
why producers are covariant goes back to
substitutability so if we need some
music
we can use something that produces a
subtype of music right we can use
something that produces death metal this
guy looks like he can definitely produce
some music for us but we can't go the
other way we can't use something that
only produces a super type of music
because if we need some music and he
asked just a general entertainer
we might get some juggling which isn't
quite what we were going for so when
something is producing a value that
container is going to be covariant with
respect to that that value it's
producing so back to functions we can
think of functions as producers of their
return type so if we look specifically
at the return type here transform shape
returns this the super type returns a
rectangle and so we can build a subtype
that returns a square and it's okay for
this subtype to return a square because
any time we need a function to produce a
rectangle it would be okay if we use one
that produces squares that's just a kind
of rectangle so let's look at
contravariance so we're gonna look at a
slightly different hierarchy so we have
energy sources and that's a super type
of vegetables and vegetables are a super
type of bamboo and so before we talked
about producers now we're going to talk
about consumers and so if you're dealing
with consumers the relationship flips so
instead of the the subtyping
relationship matching the thing that
they're consuming it actually goes the
opposite direction and again this is
because of substitutability
so if we need something that consumes
vegetables let's say we have an
artichoke and we need something to
consume this artichoke we can use
something that can consume a super type
of vegetable like a big ball of fire
that can definitely consume our
artichoke but we can't use something
that can consume only a subtype of
vegetable if we try to feed our
artichoke to a panda it's going to say I
only eat bamboo I can't consume that so
back to functions we can think of
functions as consuming their arguments
so if we need a function that can take
in a rectangle we can construct a
subtype that consumes any kind of shape
because if all we need is to be able to
pass in rectangles we can also pass in
rectangles to
that takes shapes they can definitely
take rectangles okay so so we've dealt
with functions and we've seen a little
bit why you might want covariants in
some cases when you're dealing with
producers and you want contravariance in
other cases when you're dealing with
consumers arrays are trickier so let's
let's think about whether arrays should
be covariant or contravariant or
invariant because let's say we're
building a new type system and this is
sort of like our task of the days to
figure out what we should do about
variants with arrays so let's think
about covariance right and this is what
makes intuitive sense to most people
this is what typescript does is that if
a is a subtype of beam then an array of
a is a subtype of an array of B but
we've seen that we can run into trouble
down right that if we let you pass in an
array of squares into something that
expects an array of shapes and then we
use that array of shapes as a consumer
of shapes right we're asking it to
consume or take in shapes we end up in
trouble because we're going to end up
with a circle in our array of squares
and so we've asked ourselves this the
substitutability problem right can we do
anything with an array of squares that
we could do with an array of shapes and
the problem is that you can add a circle
to an array of shapes but you can't add
a circle to an array of squares so
there's certain things that you can do
with that you can do with an array of
shapes that you can't do with an array
of squares so it's not sound to be
covariant so let's look at
contravariance maybe maybe that will
work better so this has an even simpler
example of why contravariance isn't
going to work for for arrays in most
cases is that if we're trying to use the
array as a producer right we're trying
to read a square out of our array of
squares it's not okay for us to pass in
a super type array right it's not ok for
us to pass in a general array of shapes
if we want a specifically an array of
squares because when we ask that array
of shapes to produce a square for us it
might produce a circle and so again
we've asked this substitutability
question we've said hey can we do
anything with an array of shapes that we
could do with an array of squares and
the answer is no because if we get an
element out of an array of squares it's
for sure a square if we get an element
out of an array of shapes it could be
something else it could be a circle or a
triangle or an octagon okay so
contravariance isn't isn't sound either
we can do by variance but that's gonna
both of these problems by variance just
says you can do either one so if there's
problems with either one by variance
also isn't going to be sound so what
we're left with is in variance and if
you want to be totally sound about how
you treat arrays you have to treat them
invariantly if something wants an array
of shapes you can only pass an array of
shapes okay so why are arrays covariant
and typescript the typescript team
definitely knows this and they've made
an explicit choice to handle arrays
covariantly and the answer is it comes
back to completeness and it comes back
to optimism that most of the time when
we write a function that takes in an
array we're usually just using it as a
producer we're usually just going to
read out of that array generally we're
not gonna write back to that or mutate
that argument and so it would be pretty
frustrating if we write a you know nice
simple function that gets the the name
of the first element of an array and in
this case it's totally sound and totally
valid for us to pass in a subtype right
to pass in the array of squares and it
would be pretty frustrating if
typescript said hey you can't do that
so flow does enforce this rule flow says
a razor invariant that's the something
and and our goal is to catch as many
bugs as possible we're not willing to
let bugs slip through just because it's
a little more frustrating to have to
deal with invariants and so flow will
throw an error here and we'll say hey
you can't pass this array of squares
into something that wanted an array of
shapes but it does give us this escape
hatch we can use a read-only array and
so we can basically narrow down what
we're gonna do with this array and
instead of getting a normal mutable
array that you can read from or write to
you can use it as a consumer or a
producer we're gonna say actually we
just want to read only arraign we're
only going to use this as a producer of
shapes we're never going to mutate it
and in this case flow does the sound
thing as well and lets you use this
covariantly because you can only use
this as a producer and so we've asked
this substitutability question again and
we've said can we do anything with a
read-only array of squares that we could
do with a read-only array of shapes and
the answer is yes we can just read stuff
out of it and and we can read shapes out
of out of a read-only array of squares
so back to that question of why did
typescript choose to make arrays
covariant well it's more complete but
less sound right and this is one of
those trade-offs were in maybe 95% of
cases you're not changing your
it's okay to treat it covariantly and it
would be a lot less complete if we made
you treat it invariantly so let's look
at some other languages and what's
interesting about variants is that this
is going to come up in any language that
has generics and like a subtyping
relationship which is most languages so
if we look at Python mypie uses
invariants for less so mypie does the
sound thing here and it says if you want
a list of a you cannot pass in a list of
some subtype of a but it's taking
advantage of the fact that python has
this first class concept of sequences
right so unlike in flow where it had to
introduce this brand new concept to
javascript of a read-only array in in
Python we have basically a read-only
array it's called the sequence and so
mypie says hey if you just mark all the
things you're going to use read-only as
sequences we won't bother you about
covariants because we'll let you use
these covariantly because they're
read-only they're only producers of
shapes or whatever java on the other
hand is unsound here java does the same
thing as typescript so if i have a
function in java that takes an array of
shapes i'm allowed to pass in an array
of squares and this is interesting
because some statically typed languages
will really have a sound type system and
some won't you can have unsoundness in
something like Java as well and so Java
has to deal with this by basically
inserting a runtime check every time you
write into an array to make sure that
you're writing something that's ok for
the runtime type of that array that it
basically knows hey our type checker
actually misses this class of bugs it
misses that you know you could pass this
square array in for a shape array and
try to write a circle to it so we'll
just double check that at runtime and
we'll give you a runtime type error
instead of a compile time type error go
has a different language philosophy goes
goal is to keep it as simple as possible
and so they they go with invariants so
in go if I want an array of shapes I
have to pass in an array of shapes it's
not gonna let me pass in an array of
squares and then lastly rust is a pretty
interesting example because in rust
mutability is a first class concept
right that's like very fundamental to
the language of whether your references
are mutable or not and so in rust if I
don't take if I if I take a non mutable
argument then I can't write to it
so I can't take a mutable shape and
write a circle to it I can't use it as a
consumer of circles because I've taken
it as read-only on the other hand if I
take it as mutable that works fine and I
can take my mutable shape and I can
write a circle to it I can ask it to
consume a circle for me but then rust is
going to enforce invariants so Russ's
rust is going to understand that that
thing is mutable it could be used as
either a producer or a consumer and the
only sound thing to do there is to treat
it invariantly okay so two quick quick
recap on on variance so so variance is
about how the subtyping relationship of
our higher-order types are arrays of
shapes that contain shapes inside them
relates to their contents so typescript
generally uses covariance and this makes
intuitive sense to most people that you
can pass in an array of triangles to
something that wants an array of shapes
but it's unsound if that function is
going to ask the argument to consume a
new shape so when you mutate your
arguments if you're not using it as
read-only that's gonna be unsound and
this is something where languages are
sort of all across the board so sorbet
and Java they do the same thing that
typescript does and they say look we
want our type system to make intuitive
sense we don't want to be incomplete
we're gonna assume that that you're
mostly treating things as read-only and
let you pass them covariantly some
languages like go say we we need to be
sound we also don't want to add
complexity and the overhead of making
you learn about variants and think about
variants all the time so we're just
going to go with invariant and it's
gonna be a little frustrating sometimes
but at least it's easy to give you great
error messages and it's definitely sound
and then some languages will use
underlying language constructs like
mutability right they'll take advantage
of the fact that the language
understands what's mutable what's not
and they can track that through to
understand whether it's sound to pass
something covariantly or invariantly
okay so we've taken a look at some case
studies to wrap up let's go back to
those three questions I posed at the
very beginning of the talk so the first
one is sometimes we're writing some code
and it has a pretty obvious type error
but our type checker doesn't catch it
we run typescript and typescript says
that codes great you're not going to get
any type errors and then at runtime you
get a
Piper and the answer is that what we're
looking for there is more soundness but
that's not the only goal of a type
system that a lot of tight systems also
want to be complete
they want to be fast they want to give
you great error messages they want to be
easy to learn and sometimes they're
willing to sacrifice a little bit of
soundness to let bugs like that slip
through the cracks in order to achieve
those other goals so the next question
is sometimes we write some code and
we're really sure that this code works
we've tested it we're sure that this is
valid code but a type checker is saying
hey you can't do that that's a type
error and what we're looking for there
is more completeness we're looking for a
type system to not point out things that
aren't actually problems but again
that's not the the primary goal of a lot
of type systems and sometimes the type
system might say look we need to be a
little bit less complete here we need to
have a few more false positives we need
to yell at you a couple of times when
it's it's not totally valid for us to do
that in order for us to create a type
system that's more sound and we'll catch
a different class of bugs and then the
last thing is sometimes we're digging
into our Docs or learning about a type
system and we're like man this seems
pretty complex it seems like there's a
lot of incidental complexity it seems
like this is much more complicated than
the comparable thing in something like
go or Java or rust and the answer is
that we don't have that super power that
the languages that had a type system
from day one have of being able to
design the language around the type
system in addition to the other way
around of being able to introduce new
language concepts or new constructs or
new syntax in order to sort of ease some
of these pains and we need to work with
this existing body of code that uses
runtime if statements to filter down the
types we want to understand those those
kinds of idioms and we might need to
make some more concessions there so when
you're designing a type system and in
particular a gradual type system where
you have that last constraint you're
constrained by you know the the existing
language and the existing idioms
sometimes you have to make these
trade-offs you have to pick to be more
sound or more complete and there's not
usually a clear right answer it's going
to depend on what your goals are right
so for flow the goal is catch as many
bugs as possible and there's almost no
cases where flow is going to choose to
be unsound on the other hand typescript
is a little bit more flexible there
there's those places where they're
willing to be unsound and it
change form or completeness or running
faster or generating better error
messages and so what I really wish that
I had understood better a couple years
ago when I started diving into this is
that that those philosophies and and you
know the the core goals of those
projects matter and that you need to
understand like if you're picking a type
system how is the the team behind that
type system gonna address these problems
they're gonna run into these trade-offs
and what are their sort of principles
how are they gonna gonna pick between
soundness and completeness and does that
match up with what you want do you want
to catch as many bugs as possible
because you're writing code for like a
spaceship you absolutely cannot have any
bugs at all and you're willing to put up
with whatever in order to get that that
level of guarantee or are you really
just looking to be more productive right
to help catch some errors sooner but
you're willing to trade off that
soundness for things like completeness
or speed or ease of learning so that's
the end thank you all so much I don't
think I have time for questions but I'll
hang out up here or outside the ballroom
or come grab me any time this weekend
and I would love to chat thank you so
much
[Applause]